as Jessie J stolen Channing's hearts six
months after his shocking split from
Jenna Dewan it's a new relationship that
has hit with a bang our source says
Channing and British singer Jessie J are
Davey it's still new and they're just
starting to get to know each other et
has learned they spent this past weekend
together in Seattle and eyewitness tells
us Channing attended Jessie Saturday
night concert at Showbox Soto today
Channing was spotted arriving in her
hometown of London solo Jessie remains
in the state's on tour
Channing's heights in 2015
Jessie actually presented the then
married star with an MTV Movie Award
it's been six months since he and Jenna
announced and into their marriage
many fans online have pointed out that
Jessie and Jenna share a similar look
but just who is Jessie J the 30 year old
singer is a UK sensation best known in
America for her massive hit with ariana
grande bang bang
[Music]
she also co-wrote Miley Cyrus's 2009
anthem party in the USA
so I've got Simon on 17 and I wrote part
in the USA when I was 18 I just like to
make people feel you know people who say
what do you want be able to take from
this and I'm like whatever they need you
know everybody has to move on we wanted
to be happy but it's still kind of hard
for me to say he might have a new
girlfriend no it's not you
you
[Music]